Подивіться уважно на ці обличчя.
Це 63 українські військові,
волонтери, медики, які протистоять російській агресії в Україні.
А нині,
під час саміту Великої двадцятки в Гамбурзі, на який з'їхалися лідери
наймогутніших держав світу,
ці люди звертаються до політиків із біл-бордів.
Вони нагадують світові про війну, на передовій якої вони перебувають.
А також про зобов’язaння, яке взяли на себе
в 1994 році США, Великобританія та Росія, -
захищати територіальну цілісність України
в обмін на відмову
від ядерного арсеналу.
Чи почують українців світові лідери?
Перший плакат знаходиться біля центрального входу до виставкового центру Гамбурга, де проходить саміт Великої двадцятки, і тому неодмінно всі лідери Великої двадцятки зможуть побачити обличчя патріотів нашої держави.
Перший плакат знаходиться біля центрального входу
до виставкового центру Гамбурга, де проходить саміт Великої двадцятки,
і тому неодмінно всі лідери
Великої двадцятки зможуть побачити обличчя
патріотів нашої держави.
Проект "Уважно подивіться на ці обличчя"
започаткували в 2016-му році Український кризовий медіацентр,
Посольство України у США та фотограф Роман Ніколаєв.
Доки триватиме війна - звернення не втрачає актуальності.
Особливо нині, коли "Велика девятнадцятка"
має шанс виступити єдиним фронтом
проти агресії Росії.